jp you live with your girl uh yeah i do
you live together yeah how how's that
dynamic work because you guys
literally live together you work
together you're engaged you said how
does that diet like when you get home
from
wherever there's like food on the table
or you get you know how does that work
well you know with a cooking channel
like yeah the food's kind of always on
the table but
um
i mean the i think the dynamic was like
we ended up becoming closer and become
becoming best friends because we did the
job together and i think a lot of
relationships if you don't have that
thing that can make you feel fully
connected to the person and you lose
that connection maybe through arguments
or some some little surface level stuff
then you kind of just harvest this
resentment that's kind of like brushed
under the rug but when you have to work
together you have to face this conflict
and i think that's a lot of things that
people try to hide from they don't like
conflict but you're going to have
conflict no matter what and you just got
to learn how to deal with it properly
and they don't teach a lot of people
that in school and stuff so we're just
kind of just you just see a lot of
people just yelling and screaming and
both people don't uh see where each
person is coming from and what we've
done is we learn a lot about conflict uh
resolution and how to to get back to
zero and that's having full connection
again
and have that feeling really resets
everything and and you're not you're not
stacking on and layering uh issues give
us an example like you're you're getting
an issue and you said you said you want
to
get back to zero
exactly yeah break down that metaphor so
basically um a 100 would be the worst
like you're both angry you're almost
ready to split you know
50 there's still something there even 20
like you're still like you just feel it
you know when you're sitting with them
the energy it's just awkward and uh you
don't feel safe
zero is when you're like bliss again
like it's
and it's a great place to kind of get
back to you don't have to get back to it
that day though some people think oh you
have to go to bed happy you have to go
to bed
um you know saying i love you and all
this stuff and and that's wrong
sometimes you need a whole night to
process what happened and then come back
with a clear head the next day what we
do working together constantly for 10
years is we're going to disagree it's
going to happen
ideas where we think our brand should go
she would have never approved what i'm
wearing today
um
like are you you're going out like that
you know and i get a lot of that and the
respect is here is that you have to
understand that if you want to respect
you know respect them back
not get defensive but see that they're
coming from a good place and a lot of
people get too defensive and and at that
point it's a bunch of insecurity kind of
rolls out and then you're projecting
like your own insecurities on them when
they're just trying to look out for you
and and be the best for you
let me let me ask you one more question
then i want to get victoria's opinion on
this
it sounds like you've got a very good
grasp on how you should work your
relationship the you know work
relationship dynamic
um you said something about being best
friends you always constantly hear be
best friends be best friends with your
partner
um
well i've dealt with this in
relationships uh how do you prevent
you know like i feel like we're just
roommates again you know you believe
ladies have felt this you've lived with
the guy before obviously you've never
lived with a guy
oh we're gonna get to victoria
um
but how do you avoid the whole you know
feeling like roommates dynamic you just
gotta be active you know like
consistently
like you know intimately
what does that mean well you you know
being best friends but you know at the
end of the day if you have a date night
or if you have a movie night or if
you're you're cuddling up you know i
mean you're breaking those barriers of
best friend when you do that
um and i think that when i say best
friends it's like usually like during
working hours and stuff
or just going out with other people
being best friends you're not like you
know groping each other you know not a
lot of pda but within your safe time and
your in your home
where you feel love and you feel that
um you you have you dedicate that those
times for it such as date night is a
perfect example of that if you ignore
having date night then you're going to
ignore the intimate part of your
relationship and and some people uh in
each relationship you got to juggle each
person's either drive or libido like you
know someone might be uh every day some
might be you know you have to come to a
compromise of that to also feel
fulfilled in that emotional level too jp
i gotta give you a shout out buddy you
got some game
yeah i didn't know you had this kind of
game i thought you did food
all right so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
[Music]